[Musique]
oui mais ma part elle adapte ici mise à
mal depuis cette semaine je vais
répondre la question d'une personne qui
me demandait d'expliquer nous parler un
peu du consensus dans la prise de
décision chez les premières nations les
communautés autochtones en particulier
c'est pourquoi en réflexion avec son 2e
but dans les dernières semaines par
rapport à la mobilisation qui se passe
présentement d'avoir trop tôt
le convoi de la liberté 2022 et on
parlait de l'appropriation de l'identité
ou même je dirais d'utilisation de
l'usurpation notre téléphone pour donner
une validation dans la voie des
communaux doivent être pas mais
représenter elle est entendue elle est
présent et pourquoi c'est important de
voir que le processus de consensus est
important pour les communautés comme
c'est que c'est un processus qui est
identifie très long terme et à la
manière de faire de beaucoup de
communautés autochtones
dans le monde politique où le match
d'hier est de vivre ensemble dans les
communautés donc une des idées le
consensus c'est d'avoir l'accord les
courtes ou longues rencontres et
consensuelle nous consensus de plusieurs
pouvoirs l'entièreté des membres des
communautés dans les décisions qui ont
un impact sur l'entièreté de la
communauté donc souvent on va voir des
référendums qui peuvent avoir lieu dans
les communautés sur des pressions autour
des enjeux économiques des enjeux
environnementaux et qui vont et prix
selon une forme de consensus des fois on
va voir pour qu'une décision soit
accepté il doit y avoir un référendum à
75% positif pour ou contre non c'est
trois quarts de la population plus avec
pau ou contre le projet ou pour compte
la décision pour que ça aille de l'avant
ça c'est un exemple juste pour dire
comment que ces différents imaginer
comment on ne discutait la séparation du
québec à 50 pour 51% c'est à ce point
que quand même une différence et comment
on peut voir des fois que nous
communautés séparées avec un film très
très minces dont visite consensus et
ludique de dire que bien si on n'a pas
d'accord de la communauté c'est que
l'addiction de continuer d'exister donc
on va prendre une décision et aller de
l'avant faire des décisions rapides
ont savamment politique canadienne c'est
complètement différent du consensus
pourquoi mais parce que on va faire les
lire des membres de partis politiques et
c'est parti politique le monde édition
selon les partis politiques dont ce que
celle là comme je dirais désavantage
c'est que ça vaut ancrée dans
l'imaginaire de beaucoup de gens une
identité envers un élu donc c'était du
leurs envies sans conservateurs comme
ils faire confiance aux magistrats
libéral à lui est aidé en lui et s'ils
essayent ça est plutôt que de se baser
son ce qui est porté de l'avant par une
élue on voit tout de suite qu'il porte
le chapeau pour une communauté
qui est différent de la communauté donc
cette communauté va vouloir créer un
consensus pour ses propres avantages
faut qu'une fois l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
et si on veut s'inspirer pour voir
comment ça peut être fait le consensus
en politique canadienne dans nos chats
regardez l'exemple et territoires par
exemple le territoire nouveau actuelle
le territoire du nunavut et le
territoire du nord-ouest sont des
modèles où justement les élections se
font par consensus pourquoi bien à
l'époque où sont installés des partis
politiques on faisait la politique gay
et puis il faut arrêter vos vues comme
des promesses qu'on devait
donc on veut faire le
ministre à sion donc ça a été un peu les
cd et une plus grande partie de la
population autochtone une plus grande
part ses obligations au prix de 2,20 et
sur le mode d'un consensus après un peu
de vent aussi ce que ça veut dire c'est
que chacun des élus de ce gouvernement
là était lui en tant que indépendants
dont il peut identifier à une communauté
politique
et pour la communauté des fans c'est
quand même très important c'est sûr que
cette personne ne doit représenter
l'ensemble de la communauté plutôt que
laisser davantage et son parti politique
et donc vous comprendrez que l'idée
derrière ça c'est que quand tu fais de
leadership campé dans une formule de
prendre une décision pour engrais en
gros et bien que tu as une vision car
comme tout le monde mais ce tempo même
ceux qui font pas partie des familles
même ceux qui sont pas des ennemis dans
son lit d de la communauté vont être
beaucoup plus mis en vision dans une
ville consensus que dans une des deux
partis politiques d'élection de groupe
et en plus si on remonte encore plus
loin en rien faut comprendre que les
partis politiques que les modes
politique présentement ferme la porte
souvent vous rentrez 10 et
l'accessibilité à la prise de parole des
citoyens alors qu'autrefois dans ledit
du consensus chaque personne pouvait
venir parler dire pourquoi il était pour
vous et décombres et le droit de retirer
donc se dire que maintenant certains
groupes et lui d'un menu on peut décider
pour l'ensemble de leurs et c'est ce qui
fait que des fois on convoi des
mobilisations qu'on veut mettre une
personne de tonnes ou une personne qui
représenterait le mois d'octobre ça
marche pas dans l'idée du consensus
traditionnels alors qui compte des
grandes mobilisations plusieurs
personnes qui représentent le quart en
gros on comprend qu'un consensus on
comprend que certains leaders
portaparole de leur communauté et
viennent appuyer un consensus entre
chacun des idéaux chypre d'où l'idée
dans mes dernières années des
mobilisations bagdad au moment où on
voyait des gens qui venaient de
plusieurs milieux comme nota que ce soit
la psp actuelle des groupes
traditionnels les gens du milieu urbain
des gens des communautés vue mais chut
territoires éloignés donc de voir tout
ce qu'on peut se réunir et d'avoir le
consensus de marché ensemble pour une
cause c'est ce qui a fait que cette
mobilisation la autochtone a marché mais
de dire on est à représentants
autochtones et c'est ça va à l'encontre
même des du consensus à moins que cette
personne n'a été
désigné a été mis en commun membres par
sa communauté de parler au nom de la
communauté est un des exemples que
j'aime beaucoup utilisé c'est par
exemple garder une guérilla pendant la
crise d'oka qui avait été mandaté par sa
communauté pour aller parler devant les
médias donc c'est vraiment de dire qu'un
consensus permet que les mobilisations
soit représentative que des élections
sont représentatives et même que les
prises de décision dans le consensus
après ça ne soit autre des faits et ça
évite de dire que chacun tire la
couverte de son bord alors qu'on tire la
couverte pour tout le monde alors merci
beaucoup pour la question sur le
consensus dit c'est extrêmement
intéressant il ya beaucoup
d'écrits beaucoup d'études qui avait été
fait par le passé sur les modèles
politiques sociales des communautés
autochtones avant l'arrivée des
européens je vous invite à aller lire ça
moi je trouve ça passionnant mais
et je pense
les prochaines semaines à venir on va
voir de plus en plus comment ces modèles
pour inspirer les modèles classiques
parce qu'on représente pas la limite de
chemin des modes petit canadien quand on
écoute pas une partie de sa population
alors je suis déçu mais n'hésitez pas à
partager la chronique et c'est pas nous
ont posé des questions